going live okay well welcome everybody
we are doing another one-on-one hangout
and this time I have sales expert Dave
Carlin with me on the line and Dave has
been an author on my website for a
number of years and he wrote a great
book on sales and and he's a big
baseball nut I am too and so he's here
to join us Dave welcome to the welcome
to the show
thanks for joining in well thanks for
having the oven it's great to be here do
you want to tell anybody watches a
little bit more about what you're all
about what you do who you help sure I'm
a baseball fan so it's only logical that
in 2005 my second book was called
baseline selling which is both sales
process and sales methodology which is
the centerpiece of some of the work I do
we work with companies and help them
grow sales by doing any number of things
from evaluating a sales organization to
building sales processes and
infrastructure and architecture to doing
development training and coaching of
sales leadership to training and
coaching of salespeople and along with
that we help with recruiting and we hope
help with career paths and we help with
skills and if it has anything to do with
the sales organization we do that at
curling associates and then my other
company objective management group is a
sales assessment company so we have the
leading Salesforce evaluation and sales
candidate assessment tools on the planet
very cool so what's the biggest problem
people face with sales they don't sell
enough so how do you have well usually
the problems are in any one of a number
of areas either at the top of the funnel
they're not finding and getting enough
new opportunities in the middle of the
funnel they're not getting traction and
engagement velocity or at the end of the
funnel they're not closing business or
closing it in a an appropriate amount of
time and those problems are usually
caused by
non-supportive sails DNA they've got
weaknesses that are getting in their way
or its skills strategies and tactics
that they haven't learned and mastered
and can't call on at the ideal moment
and then a little bigger picture than
that in many cases the company doesn't
have a repeatable sales process that
yields consist in effective results so
the first thing we do is try to find out
why they're struggling and then from
there we can give them the help they
need so if I'm an entrepreneur and I
have a new product I'm trying to get it
out there and I'm struggling to get the
sales that I want I think I have a great
product great service but I'm really
starting to get it out there and get the
sales what am i what are my options
what's the best thing to do should I
invest in myself and become a better
salesperson should I hire sales person
to come aboard what do you recommend
well it's a great question because the
entrepreneur needs to make it work
there's really no option to not grow
sales but not every entrepreneur has the
DNA or the makeup to be effective
selling especially if they're selling
themselves which is a little harder for
a lot of people than selling a product
or selling a service so the logical
first step is to evaluate so that we can
take a look at whether the entrepreneur
has the right sales DNA or has some
skill gaps that we can fix and then
determine that it might make more sense
for them to hire a salesperson or if
they've got the right potential help
them become more effective so let's talk
about that potential that DNA what are
one of the some of the things that
you'll look at to figure out you know so
entrepreneurs watching this so trying to
figure out okay Dave said I need to have
the salesman DNA how do I figure out if
I've got that or not what are some of
the questions that you ask
look there are there are six things that
that we look for that help us understand
the sales DNA and in an entrepreneur one
of them is how much they need to be
liked the psychological term would be
need for approval but how much do you
need to be liked and if
you need to be like their love too much
that gets in the way because you won't
be able to ask the tough question you
won't be able to confront somebody and
push back and challenge their thinking
and you'll accept put offs all day long
because you'll be afraid to save a thing
that could get them upset so that's one
of the areas we look at another area we
look at is how they buy things
themselves
we call it buy cycle so an entrepreneur
that needs to think everything over will
generally accept that kind of behavior
from a prospect I'll let them think it
over indefinitely an entrepreneur that
looks for the lowest price will
understand it when their prospect needs
a lower price an entrepreneur that
comparison shops will understand it when
the prospect wants to compare them to a
couple of other companies an
entrepreneur that thinks a relatively
small amount of money is a lot of money
will understand it when a prospect says
tease that seems expensive so that's the
second piece of DNA a third piece we
look at is how well they control their
emotions whether they can stay in the
moment and if they're unable to stay in
the moment and they react and panic they
can lose control of the sales process
because they'll be listening to
themselves instead of their prospect how
do you how do you test that you put them
in a stressful situation no we have we
have these world-class sales assessments
that I developed and continue to develop
and improve over the last twenty four
years and they're very accurate and they
tell us exactly how someone will do in a
sales situation so that's three examples
so first step is they're gonna they're
gonna buy your so how much is your
assessment to assess just themselves it
would be four hundred dollars okay so
they're gonna spend four new dollars and
they get this package at then they get
shipped to them or they download it or
what's the process we'll e-mail it to
them okay so they fill it out and then
that will tell them if they have the DNA
or not to be yes exists that'll go
through everything relative to the
strengths that they have that'll support
the use of skills and tactics and
strategy
it'll identify the weaknesses that get
in the way of those skills and tactics
and strategies and it'll identify the
gaps in their skills or us so that
they'll see exactly why they're
struggling whether or not there's any
hope and what they can do about it and
from there they can either choose to
hire a salesperson get some training get
some coaching or ignore it bury their
head in the sand that's not the answer
so that first one of I need to be liked
right that's your first part of the DNA
so do salespeople need to be like the
good salesperson needs to be liked is
that is that what the times good ones
don't need to be liked yeah like I don't
need to be like they they're generally
likeable but they don't need it it
doesn't validate them they're more
interested in having someone respect
them or good I love them you know so you
know you can get the love from a dog
right or me or maybe from your salsa
lessons right right right cool so this
is also like a deep introspective dive
into your psyche here this isn't just my
sales not not so deep into the psyche
only only the part of the psyche that
supports selling okay and he and need
for approval is probably the only place
we go that could be related to the
psyche the rest of it it's got more to
do with bravery and comfort level okay
that it has to do with any deep-seated
psychological issues okay so I can spend
my core in the box I get my tests and I
will tell me if I'm gonna be a good
salesperson or not so then for the for
the skills part what are some of the
skills that you find so if I've
determined okay yeah I have the DNA to
be a salesperson but I'm not getting my
sales here wait a minute some of the
skills right so then it's probably a
matter of which skill gaps are there and
a lot of salespeople have top of the
funnel skills but they don't have the
middle and bottom of the funnel skills
so they can find opportunities but they
can't
Ferengi ate themselves they they aren't
selling consultative ly it's too
transactional so they're not drawing out
the compelling reasons why somebody
would spend their money with them
instead of with somebody else and
they're not selling value some of them
don't have skills in the area of
qualification so they're not really
finding out whether the opportunity is
viable most of them are pretty good at
presenting and talking about their
capabilities and generating proposals
and quotes so it's the stuff that
happens prior to the presenting and the
demoing it's it's consultative selling
and qualifying where most of the skill
gaps are and then there's a big group of
people that are horrible at the top of
the funnel if they get a prospect on the
phone or they're communicating via email
or they're out in the social selling
world they don't know how to have that
first interaction of that first
conversation that'll get somebody to
raise their hand say I'm interested in
schedule a first meeting got it oh okay
you know I just got a question from
someone who's watching on YouTube
Jason Hiro didn't say hi they have an
Evan love what I'm hearing Napoleon Hill
says we are all salesmen regardless of
our calling how does this relate the
people who don't have Dave's sales DNA
well he's right Napoleon Hill did say
that but there's a difference between
convincing a family member or a friend
to go to the movie or convincing them to
choose this restaurant over that
restaurant and putting money on the
table and then having to convince
somebody to choose us instead of the
alternative and pay us what we want for
what we're trying to sell them so as
soon as money and competition enters the
equation everything changes can you so
Jason's asked him to expand can you
expand on the difference there sure if
if I reach out to you and say hey Evan
how about interviewing me on your video
YouTube channel you say yeah there's no
money riding on that there's no win
there's no loss if it's good for both of
us we'll do it on the other hand if I
say hey
Evon would you be interested in paying
me $10,000 for me to appear on your
YouTube video now I've added money into
the equation now it's a tough decision
for you now there may not be any gain
for you but the gain might all be for me
so the whole thing has changed just
because we've added money okay so let's
get to so thanks Jason for writing in
let's get to that difference you're
talking about sales people and some
people are good at the top of the funnel
and some people aren't and they have
skills that they're missing do we is it
better to go and learn those skills at
the top of the funnel or is it better to
have somebody who's kind of the hunter
and the lead acquisition and then you
focus on the closing what what what
great question great question if you've
got the DNA to support it and we talked
about some of that DNA whether or not
they need to be liked and another pieces
whether they can recover from rejection
because rejection is part of selling so
it's not whether or not they're going to
get rejected they're going to get
rejected but how do they react to that
respond to that can they get right back
on the phone or does it take 10 minutes
or 10 hours or 10 days or 10 weeks
before they can do it again so how much
they need to be like how they recover
from rejection and how they feel about
picking up the phone and making a call
it goes into whether they can learn to
be good at it so if the DNA supports it
then we can teach them how to do it but
they've got to change themselves a
little bit it's more than words they
need to have the right tonality they
need to sound engaging they need to be
willing to go away from a script it's a
script that approach without a script so
there's a process they would need to
follow and they've got to get away from
just telling people who they are what
their company is and what they're
selling and asked to meet with them
they've got to take a more scientific
approach so that they can get people's
attention and get them engaged and learn
the right words to to get their
attention with a positioning statement
so
yes they can learn it with supportive
DNA but there's a lot to it which might
explain why so many of them suck so bad
at it so the DNA will tell me fight if I
have the ability to do that first part
yeah you do then I should hire you're
fine I'm fine
I didn't go through the tests I know but
I developed the test I already know I'm
liking it I'm liking it okay let's talk
about your book so baseline selling it's
it's a baseball theme for those of you
haven't seen it it is if there's a you
know picture of baseball players on it
how does baseball relate to this Alan
I'm a baseball fan so I'm curious well
there's a bunch of neat analogies that
the appendix in the back of the book has
about thirty analogies but the the two
that are most important is that we can
use the baseball diamond itself as a
visual sales process so you can use the
basis as a way to trace the evolution of
the sales process it goes from suspect
the prospect to qualified to closable
first base second base third base home
and we can lay out the steps and the
milestones in the sales process on the
base paths that's one way it works
probably the the coolest place that it
works I don't know how much time we have
you have to time for a five-minute story
yeah okay so one of the milestones
between first and second base the the
part of the sales process where we're
selling consultative ly and trying to
differentiate ourselves we call it sob
quality in this case sob stands for
speed on the bases so you know for
watching a baseball game and the
speedster reaches first base the color
analyst says well there's speed on the
bases so what that ends up meaning is
that everybody in the stadium knows he's
gonna try and steal second so the
pitcher starts to go into defensive
tactics and starts throwing over to
first base to maybe take a step or two
off the lead to show that he's paying
attention maybe to tire him out he's got
a slide and dive back into
first-base every time and eventually
he's got a pitch to the hitter but the
hitter has an advantage now because he
knows a fastball is coming there's a big
gap on the right side of the infield
because the first baseman's on first
base
second baseman's come in a bit and over
towards second to take a throw on an
attempted steal and play for a double
play so the the next hitter with great
bat control has an advantage where he
knows it's a fastball and he's got the
whole right side of the infield to punch
it through so the the base stealer has
changed the energy of the game and has
taken over the game by getting the
pitcher to pay more attention to him
than the hitter if we translate that to
selling we as sales people have
developed sob quality when we get the
prospect to pay more attention to us
than all of our competitors and we do
that by building a better relationship
by showing that we care by showing that
we're listening by differentiating
demonstrating our expertise and we do
all of that by asking questions asking
more questions better questions tougher
questions than the competition until
we've had the kind of conversation with
a prospect that nobody else has ever had
with them and that game-changing
differentiating conversation is the
culmination of developing speed on the
bases sob sob will be I was buried
you're right exactly
I guess gone he's gone he's been
pinstripes now was the new speedster in
Boston Jackie Bradley is replacing
Jacoby Ellsbury he's a rookie so he's
not as fast as Jacobi buddy's he's got
all the tools of jacobian now we'll see
how it plays out at the major league
level very and what about up in Toronto
this year they're supposed to have a
good team we'll just have a good team
last year but we'll see supposed to have
a good team every year I was excited
last year with all this all the trades
everything but I don't know we'll see
I'm confident yeah you guys got the same
roster from the Florida Marlins that
didn't succeed with the Florida Marlins
it's like digging it in there okay so
back on top tip to develop those skills
and ask better questions and develop my
sob is it training with you guys is it
going through this assessment tool is it
reading your book is it a combination
like how do I so I know I have a gap in
skills how do I get better well if the
evaluation shows that you know there are
some weaknesses and some skill gaps then
we can do some training or and/or some
coaching so what we're talking about
right now between first and second base
with developing sob that's that's all
listening and asking questions and most
salespeople even the good salespeople
are deficient when it comes to really
good listening skills and being able to
ask spontaneous questions based on what
they're hearing so training and coaching
is the answer to that and sure you can
read the book is there is there just for
everybody watching is there even an
example you can go through or a client
wait a minute without naming names but
someone who epitomized that was not
great at listening and it cost them and
how he came and helped them and how you
fix them geez we can probably point to
every client when I do that because as
soon as as soon as you can teach
salespeople or entrepreneurs to
effectively listen and ask questions
everything changes everything changes
the way a prospect looks at you changes
the way they share information with you
changes the amount of time they give you
changes the amount of attention they
give you changes you go from salesperson
or a vendor to trusted advisor so you
basically get to the point where they
won't do anything without talking to you
so in a typical company once we get a
Salesforce to go through that transition
with a typical entrepreneur once we get
them individually to go through that
transition it can take several months to
develop and master the
skills we usually see them double their
revenue it's great is there is it a
mindset you need to develop is it asking
certain questions I have to believe they
must believe guard
it starts with mindset they have to know
that it's okay they have to know that
they can they have to know that no one's
gonna get upset with them and tell them
to stop asking questions cuz a lot of
them are afraid that well I can't ask
those questions I can't push back I
can't challenge but that's how you
differentiate yourself by challenging
conventional thinking and pushing back
on something that was said and asking
for explanations and not having all the
answers and until you identify a problem
you can solve and understand the
consequences of that problem and the
impact and can quantify it and put a
dollar amount on it and be able to share
with a prospect so we're talking about a
10 million dollar problem right and
that's a game-changer so to get to that
to get to those problems is there is
there a common type of question a common
scenario where sales people are afraid
to push back on something and they kind
of like yeah there's always example they
always think they've asked enough
questions they always assume they know
what the problem is they always assume
it's the same problem that everybody
else has but it's if they can ask so
tell me a little more about that a
couple more times so tell me how that
manifests for you but give me an example
of the last time that happened or when
that happened who bore all the pressure
of that who did that impact person who
else cares about that what do they say
about that so it's it's basically the
polite English language version of more
more MORE okay limit let me shift gears
to I have a question that from an
entrepreneur friend of mine okay he has
a sales guy and they fight over how much
research you need to do before you call
up a client so
his sales guy Hassan he likes to do a
lot of research and look at the website
look at every page understand their
business and my entrepreneur friend is
saying just call them and start a
conversation and they'll tell everything
you need to know and he gets upset that
a sales guy takes so long it feels like
he could be calling a lot more people if
you didn't spend so much time
researching what what are you what's
your advice for that kind of situation
your entrepreneur friend is right just
pick up the phone and call now okay you
need to know enough to know that they're
an appropriate target that they fit a
profile that they're in our sweet spot
we need to know if if we solve the kinds
of problems that are relevant to what
they might be in the news for and to
what might be on their website we might
need to know that they have the things
going on that we can help with but but
short of that get on the phone and make
the call or go into your LinkedIn
Network and find somebody that can
introduce you to break the ice and lower
the first barrier so that you don't have
to make a cold call but do it get on it
be Nike just do it be Nike and believe
and believe you got it that's right what
do you recommend for someone who'd like
to get over that fear to call somebody
especially cold calling right people are
just afraid afraid to follow up afraid
to make that first initial call - how do
you get over that fear you might not
that like I said some people don't have
sales DNA that will support cold calling
and it's not fair to ask that person to
cold call if in their DNA they don't
have what it takes to support doing that
all you're gonna do is just drive them
nuts and cause them to feel bad about
themselves because they're going to
underperform they're going to
underachieve they're going to fail so
you've got to put them in a role that
they're better suited for and if cold
calling isn't what they're best suited
for let's not make them do it
we can't change their DNA so what you
have a good salesperson like if they're
not good at cold calling can they still
be and they still do the rest of it they
can
and and they can work with the issue
they can work their customer base for
referrals and introductions if they know
they're not gonna make you know forty
cold calls a day
well fine as long as they can find
enough new opportunities some other way
as long as they can do if you marketing
do referrals do introductions to being
out there speaking engagements do videos
just some way of getting found so that
they don't have to rely on cold calls
this is great Dave I really appreciate
all the time today it's been great to
meet you kind of face to face well we
we've emailed back and forth over the
last several years old market times I
know this is the first time we've
actually spoken it's great it's just a
wrap-up if people are interested in
learning about your book or they want to
you know get your assessment or they
want to do some coaching or training
with you what's the best way for people
to find you they can email me the easy
email address is Dave at baseline
selling calm okay I'm all over the web
find me on LinkedIn you can my blog oMG
like oh my god hub hu b.com that the
blog is understanding the Salesforce oMG
is short for objective management group
the assessment company so oMG hub calm
objective management calm kerlun and
associate kerlun associates.com just
Google Dave kerlun if you need to reach
me I'll be there or of course on your
site right you're through yeah
absolutely q-final never chemical calm
thank you so much David really
appreciate all the time thanks for
having me Evan it was great fun good
luck